you married some things what man watch
the show show bismillah alhamdulillah
assalamu alaikum
we're greeting with the best greeting
the greeting of peace peace be with you
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Deen show
I'm Eddie your host and today we have a
double treat for you
we're gonna be talking to mr. Shaikh
brother Hassan that's right he was in
the music industry for 40 years 40-plus
years he's here to tell us his story how
he went from singing to people such as
Ronald Reagan to singing also to the
former president of Yugoslavia Tito and
some of the higher clerks up in the
church that's right the church and also
different Imams such as sheikh bend the
rules and whatnot to finally finally
after being a one who was not so Muslim
to a part-time Muslim to once in a while
culturally Muslim to this debt and the
other to get him back on track we want
to hear his story they would say
sometimes that you can't teach an old
dog new tricks but let me tell you
something as he's gonna testify today
that you know what when the truth comes
to you when you realize that hey I'm
gonna die sooner or later I'd better get
my act together and I better seek
guidance from the one who created me
he's best to tell me how to live my life
and when that truth comes and you see
the goodness that comes out from
following that truth you start to leave
off some of these vices you start to
leave off many of the things that are of
no benefit the things that don't produce
a positive outcome in your life things
that don't help you to become the best
human being but they kind of bring you
down so he left this and we want to hear
his story so we can all benefit the
young and the old the rich and the poor
and it's a double treat because we have
come out and Mickey who's gonna be
conducting the interview helping us out
here before we begin with this week's
show we also want to inform you about
the new mq-- Muslim quarterly magazine
it's out in bookstores near you Barnes
and Noble and borders and you can order
it online now when you
order it online you can get the Dean
show volume 2 for free that's right for
free so go ahead and pick up this
magazine you'll have myself and my
brother professor Adam black belt in
Gracie Brazilian jiu-jitsu we'll be
conducting the self-defense portion of
the magazine the fitness section so this
is a great deal for you get the magazine
and get the Dean show DVD with two discs
in one case for free that's right for
free that's the latest news now when we
come back that's right
Hasan is telling his story with Kimmel
and Mickey here on the Dean show I'll
see you next week God willing inshallah
enjoy this week's show
Sonam alaikum peace be with you allahu
salat wa salam o allah my name is kamala
Miki and today we have actually a very
special guest with me in the studio is
brother Hassan Reds of itch and brother
Hassan read the which ended by the way
it hurts me to call you brother I wanted
to call you chef out of respect but
because of his humbleness may Allah
reward him he actually refused that I
referred to him as shear but our brother
Hassan dreads which actually has a very
interesting life and we want to talk
about some of his experiences and
something else is very interesting for
all the Deen show fans if we can get the
camera on brother Hassan where the
Hassan is actually the father of Eddie
the host of the Deen show so for those
who have been wondering for the past
years where Eddie gets his good looks
from alhamdulillah in this episode we
finally have the answer to that question
so first of all salam alikum and welcome
to the show and it we've already been
talking a little bit and i'm very
excited to get started we'd like to get
started by by asking you you know when
you were born
well you don't have to tell us the dates
but we're at least and what the
atmosphere was like the family was like
if you would begin in child
this is my surprise I even was not
prepared very thick but thanks to Allah
to be with you than today I'm born about
60 years ago in former Yugoslavia
today's Bosnia 1949 I'm born in a small
town but everybody know he said about
7,000 people in big family so-called I
would not say the poor but he was little
so called poor on poor you know father
mother
five six brothers and five sisters after
second world war
can you imagine today you have one child
little too much that time alone is No
thank God you know I can tell you know
that we don't have that but logic child
him today at that time but thank God I
don't know now he was hundred percent
and you know with us ok now just if you
could give us an idea because some
people may not have an idea after World
War two who is in charge of Yugoslavia
was it under Russian control many people
would imagine it was under Russian
control but the reality is not about
that time when I was born there was one
system communist and was Tito a marshal
he was the one system you know one party
ok
and honestly whoever was enjoying the
party they had a good time
rest of it there was struggling my
father he was working by himself you
know like I said then also what can you
accept you know on top of everything he
he choose a little bit alcohol also that
was affect every little bit even today
for
this disease and the music he loved the
music he start also he sounded like you
know in me kinda that he can get me to
be like singer you know and that's the
stuff was that about six seven year old
he was waking up night time bringing in
the gypsies you know violence and
playing music but just to clarify this
with this was he was Muslim by name this
was a Muslim family by name yes he was
like Mahmoud may heard a short in Bosnia
you know they even even we you know hot
Sun how so
you know like Yuri v8 the name it was
like you know kind of shy to say who you
are and would you be if your name was
Muhammad Muhammad would you find
problems from the government not really
not not really but okay I now I can see
like you know they played played a very
nice role about you know this religion
my father left me a to to good good
advice okay the number one is he took me
to the Imam and tell him mom listen he
is a Hassan you'll meet my boss Oh
teach him by Allah excellent even my
father he wasn't afraid like he was part
time Muslim now could you explain what
it means your meet my bones because
leaders don't understand even you will
be there bidding but let them know
teacher that's that's God is this
beautiful just running by the viewers
one more time you're meeting my bones
meaning you can whip them and beat them
you can take care of the meat just give
me bones at the end there so now there
are some cultures where they tell the
teacher your bones my meat so you beat
him and break his bones just give me the
me brother okay
this word one second since my birth
father is born in smaller village huh
and he have to signal he came to this
little big effort where we are in where
I'm the order what happened one day we
was going to visit his you know
visit his relatives our relatives and we
all of people they know him
one villages Orthodox Serbs there who
come on they bring in alcohol you know
Muslim day every day
chai bringing food and then after all he
got drunk and the way he said he told me
it's just Oh son actually I I told
father your mother about you you so
popular listen build a house in every
village how I can small how that's way
that I mean that's what he meant be good
with everybody
oh they won't love you Isis least those
two I forgive him child abuse I've that
we call child abuse he abused me with
the music I see music that everybody
think the music is something sweet
oh brother I am professional 40 years in
the music business worst years for zero
okay let's go to the beginning you said
when you were six or seven years old my
father waking up to those gypsies
violins oh I want my son to sink Oh
teaching teachers look and I've asked 14
I have my own group following Beatles
long here baby baby Bella Bella you know
14 1966 guess what I have another band
more bigger I start early morning 1415 I
I seek to the teacher the president of
the country so you got one fourth of
July they're gathering all of it they
gave him I sing there so you got to that
level you that famously sign now I start
earning money from music bringing money
doesn't this when I was 18 I went to
army no school
actually let me go back today to the
Imam every mom I go regular school I go
a regular school come late or you know
that he paints 11 kids not perfect
perfect perfect
I'm sorry to interrupt you said after
the Imam so you studied with the Imam
yes Islam yeah so your father be with
the Imam but he also took you to study
with the gypsies no no no no today will
our school okay all right cool
excellent you know regular school when I
go over there if I mentioned God was it
what guy god no God God oh did you see
that shut up then I was confused
confusion you see let's say those
reaches reaches from Muslim or you know
there was two different kind of Orthodox
and Muslim in my town there was no no
others like you know maybe one of
thousand but what happened now
I've confused when this the richest
Muslim is son doesn't go to my knowledge
it wow that's not popular what's wrong
command and that's a society we live
live just a Muslim there that's it but
just by name or by man that's it alright
okay so going back to the music then you
start to sing in front of the the
president and then from there where did
it go to Iran then I buy all on band we
play here and there because you know we
we play you know parties you know and
everything and I actually don't know she
said in school and I went to army in
army hold 16 months actually 18 but 16
months I play in with our deep Arab army
bent in the town of Banja Luka you know
after their army I finished I go to
Adriatic in Yugoslavia
that's a popular place it's really kind
of party
that's a festivals I then I start also
nightclubs Oh
playing like nice nightclubs good time
worshipping music which is earlier you
were talking to you about what I'm funny
now like thank you know in 20s now when
I'm on our 20 or 80 and then my brother
older brother even to Germany and he
called me after one year he said come on
over for you
he arranged for me to work and also
music always drawing music music music
could you just explain to our viewers
what you were telling me earlier what
comes with music so people can imagine
the lifestyle
okay now I'm not to there now let's say
okay thank God - one actually he was he
wants to serve orthodox he get me from
nine ten eleven twelve yet you know he
does this man he was a boxer he was a
singer and he was also also truck driver
and then he he teach me not to drink not
to smoke but okay woman okay so with all
this music there was no drinking there's
no no okay that's rare
all right now what happened I spent I
left Yugoslavia in 1970 and then I also
with the music and everything and
working mostly the was nightlife and you
know after that every three six months I
was driving down to to Yugoslavia also
singing also when they calling me to
tell training anyway in 1973 I met my
wife that time she was in America and
then we met yes
just one time this is yet today
next day I offer you her you know
marriage you didn't waste any time
no my kind of girl excellent dead
serious what happened after all we went
to Germany she begged to
America 1974 actually in the four or
five months papers was finished I came
to America 1974 okay
music big time in Canada always up and
down you know and then finally I came to
Chicago 1977 that time I had Eddie Eddie
God gave me maybe he actually he is both
born in before New York iced over lived
there when I came to America I don't
like I don't like it I start drinking
with the reason because you missed the
reason Germany I was crying for German
the popularity and everything over there
okay different you know anyway guess
what I start now to all the time I was
chasing the microphone praying to
microphone enter woman now comes alcohol
for the first time alcohol comes
actually in Germany I tried that they
call that don't call beer that's like
for ladies they drink he does beer for
ladies you know nothing but now they
don't know how its can whiskey with mix
laughing whatever is there you know
anyway again also this bridge America
Yugoslavia once twice a year I always I
was going over there if there's any any
any you know concerts or anything to to
you know when the price go over there
they can Ford recording you know and
then I record some some you know some
cassettes some albums some DVDs you know
and then what happened all of this to
this life outside when I moved to
Chicago then I I bought that nightclub
Europe at night is bought one yes he
called Europe at night Europe at night
a Greek time show also called stars
Miroslava Serbs most Muslims for Bosnia
hated their band anyway now it's 2-2
kids I had daughter 1989 and then what
happened
finally I I couldn't make it
thank God I sold it nightclub after that
after that i i i went to yugoslavia
mostly also what's what was going on
with with my music taking me but one
main main key is my mother my father he
passed away before I get married and
left country what happened my mother
that time it that I don't know I love
her more than then then God don't Allah
I was not not not believe really ok
because I was look the way I see now I
was really not that I should be you know
but also allowing my mother I was
thinking when when I go sometime to the
graves you know somebody died June as
you know I was thinking what I gonna do
when my mother died and I was watching I
told I will kill myself I will lay down
with her let them cover me you know how
anyway my mother she pays to in 1995 war
start in in the former Yugoslavia in
Bosnia start 1992 by watching this and
television here and there trying to help
the families back and forth back and
forth anyway
what happened 1995 my mother she passed
away and then 1996 1996 I went to Bosnia
for stop I went to Bosnia with my
daughter with my wife in I went over
there to do what specifically actually
to visit my daughter she wanted study
okay until then I was let's talk about
like say my Dean
you know the lesion I was not visiting
just you know on one time a week you
know what Sunday not even Friday
you know mosque go pray show show up
over there what's you know so there was
some beginning now yes no that's why
it's all the time here in America yes
why because this I was singing 1981 I
went to to South Slavic Festival in
Washington that kind of was Reagan and
Nancy I sing in one big house again yes
yes yes
and then then over here
although Yugoslav tops ambassadors
consuls all of those Orthodox Christians
in those you know that the Catholics
priests is here and their day in their
community mostly mouths or Imams many
moms here I go and sing today then I
told this that's that's really that's
okay and then when I visit 1996 Bosnia I
could not believe we used to drinks
together chase the girls together do
everything you know I'm talking about
the neighbors but you know it was no
different who you are
oh yeah all you were slow your deaths in
this no religion no religion no God
okay I clo3 village
burned and I met who over there
one American officer actually police
international policeman and his husband
we need you here
I need you here when I come back I start
you go I mean American army peacekeeping
peacemaking force that's translator you
know my son anyway so you want as a
translator yes I went over there it was
every door was open for us when I went
and listening to these people follow
them thank to Allah and some of these
people were people you grew up with that
you knew I know you heard their stories
okay look like so I'm gonna stop you
there we'll take a quick break and when
we return inshallah we'll continue with
our brother Hassan reservation Charlotte
no speech is better than to do that
would call people to Allah and to do
there were no speeches better you know
nothing is better than that is it true
that if one person I'm the Allah giving
you an ability to guide someone should a
lot of Commission the credit Commission
that was better than everything in this
world but in the whole world and
everything that's in it in another
narration it's better than the best of
wealth but if we really felt that Eddie
would we not be getting out giving them
and this is something that we encourage
all the MSAs
all the dowel organizations the mustards
to get this we want to print more we
give these to the novices for free for
free for free we want our brothers
so now I craft Oliver Catherine welcome
back in this special edition of the Dean
show we're talking to brother Hassan red
the [ __ ] who as I said in the beginning
is actually the father of the host of
the Dean show Eddie and we we left off
when you were a translator in Bosnia and
you were talking to people that you grew
up with and they were telling you what
had happened and and basically if I
understood you correctly now there was a
split before it didn't matter if you
were Orthodox Christian Muslim but now
it mattered yeah
now really doesn't matter but what what
happened to me it's my god that I
believed my mother she passed away
okay but the day when she passed away
Allah made so easy for me I was thinking
I don't kill myself I don't lay down you
didn't think you did when I go there
must be a god it's no let me find out
really you know why why is this happened
by talking people I started praying I
start even in the base over there we
have tent and then I I get off just you
know army in 1998 first first thing what
happened I come back to us I joined the
group go to Hajj Hajj that's my first
day of of my life to live like Muslim
five day praying like so and trying go
on keep going keep going copy after dead
1 2 3 4 5 1999 2000 1 2 3 5 times Allah
guide me to Mecca Medina excellent I've
time uniform a lot and then like I see
here here's the tank you know what
happened to me now
I know Allah like II know him me when I
was really baby he don't he was always
with me
I was disconnect I was part-time Muslim
believer but part-time Muslim doesn't
exist I will I will say Allah look now
after five years miracle happened to me
again another one
I can be a Content Hajj I made height
for my father my Allah accepting for my
mother when I came 2003 miracle happened
I came home the day my wife she says her
son Eddie he's got a present for you she
bring it home guess what
could an in bars in translation I hear
one but that's my best present I can
help Eddie brought it for you
I shall and and how old was he when your
brother guess what happened now
next morning next morning we lived where
the school is like two miles away in my
house and Eddie left by himself over
there in the morning budget I woke up
see what happened he said you know you
take something here Palestine
daddy let's go pray I don't see it she
also part time plane how old was it now
so we understand this is this was 2003
ok 2003 so he's working out professor
even next to my house is messy okay
can gonna be ready you know I was tired
from [ __ ] that this I mean from young
for much no no he says we go MCC it's
like two three months way down two miles
lease you know more reward he says my
jaw out of fat that's what happens
would you what was your specifically not
a fact what was your do I not remember
one is you know save me my family
hundred exodar for the family and then
your son the next and then my my family
who the sees that and then also from all
OMA hola beautiful every guide well I I
don't see now let's say that different
because the people is they don't know
they don't see you know now they ask in
what house and why don't you sing why
don't you this why doesn't listen if you
give me whole world well lie hola
don't don't let me go to the microphone
guess what also five years shaitan the
satan he was playing with my mind once a
we gave a music night he tricked me
we go over there let me tell you this
what happened with one placing over here
Chicago and I go thinking I go in this
bar nightclub where the music's that's
kind of singing they know me they came
like so-called star from Serbia lady and
them this man do we know each other for
three five years
Zoran College each led a luggage she's a
king lady from Serbia news o'clock or
the night what happened I think just to
telling you know look I drink chai tea
or juice who is the happiest me you are
caught another thing you know just to :
to to to worship God no no no music no
but what happened next day Eddie called
me sir Jerry we got home people become
he came to my van so what's going on is
this okay that you go over the night
clubbing and now I so who you to tell me
you know like you know my life see how
did ignosi
what happened how do is he
how did he find out he had someone's fun
is that some Bosnia Sunday calling in my
brother they readily this is small or
like yeah what happened then he said I
was kind of hey you telling me I'm your
father you like I don't wanna shut up by
the way you know you you don't have to
tell me what to do I know my knee like
my finger and he got mad if you think
the medics marking that you know angel
working in the indian day in this in
this nightclub over there and you
calling God to help you over there you
go Allah to three blocks our staff says
it it's like four five years thank
there's so many people still in this
lifestyle they think they're happy
they're chasing happiness like this yeah
you know we're actually we're actually
going to end we have a very little time
left and there's probably still a lot
more that we can hear from you and you
know what may Allah reward you and
accept from you your good deeds and your
amendments and mail exit from your
family and bless them for you into you
which is which is a very nice
relationship that that
naseeha goes both ways from the father
to the son and the son to the Father as
well so that's a great blessing so
brother hasn't done it was a pleasure
talking to you would like to thank you
very much for sharing and I would like
to thank everyone else for watching and
inshallah we'll continue at another time
talking a little bit more about the you
know the the world in the pull of the
the Shaitaan were drawn to a lot for
watching salaam wa barik alaa muhammad
wa ala he was a big man mr. America
the profits they submit to him alone
whether you're rich or you borrow the
gift of life is worth much more than
gold